Okay, and by the way, guys, you can all hear me, right?
Yeah.
Cool.
Awesome.
Let's do this thing.
Let's guys today.
I want to talk about low ticket versus high ticket.
First of all, I want to let you guys know what I'm going to do is anybody that's watching
this entire call that's on this the entire time.
We are going to just like last time, we're going to screenshot your name and we're going
to send you.
We're going to take all the information that we have in this presentation and distill it
down to something that's like consumable, like some type of a digital resource, whether
it's a list, whether it's a whatever the case is, Aaron's going to create it and everyone
that stays on this call the entire time is going to actually get that resource.
Okay, so just stay on and then you don't have to worry like we will give it away to a couple
people in the free group, but you guys don't have to worry about like commenting and stuff
like that.
So just so you know, that's kind of the thing that we're going to do to incentivize you
guys.
We want we want you to stay on.
Okay, so one thing that I realized this week as I was preparing for this and I was I was
doing my own education for myself, I realized that sometimes I assume that everybody knows
who I am, you know, like they know my entire story.
And because I've said it so many times, it becomes very boring to repeat.
But I want to just quickly, I basically want to just let you guys know if you're new to
this, if you're new to this group, you're new to this, this space, rank and rank digital
real estate, I want to like give you a reason to consider listening to me.
Okay, I don't think you should believe everything that I say or anything that I say, I think
you should test everything.
But I want to give you a reason to consider listening to what I have to say.
So quick background, 2016, I was knocking door to door.
I was tired of it.
I needed something that was online.
I wanted to travel the world.
By the way, here we are in Dubai doing exactly what I wanted to.
It's amazing.
I wanted something that was recurring.
I wanted to be able to have a life for my family, my kids and give them experiences.
And so in 2016, I got into this game.
I took my own advice that I give it and I found somebody that had a program and I did
the call and the whole thing, not even thinking I was getting sold.
And sure enough, I got sold and yeah, it was a thing between me and my wife.
She wasn't super excited about it, but I made a lot of money from it.
So I always remind her that I made a good decision.
So I've been in the game for eight years.
There was a little hiatus in there where I got some shiny object syndrome.
I tried to start a software company, but I've been in this game for eight years.
I've also spent and lost millions of dollars making mistakes, including at one point four
or five million dollars.
And I think it's a little bit higher than that now just on ads.
And I did that.
And the reason why I have this group is so that you guys don't have to, you don't have
to go make the one point four or five million dollar lessons.
I can teach them to you.
OK, so eight years in 2020, I finally figured it out.
There was some missing pieces.
That program that I was in, it was good, but there was missing pieces.
There just there was a lot of stuff that just these little things.
And finally, in 2020, I was able to scale.
I figured it out.
I nailed it.
And we went from eight thousand dollars a month in December of 2019, where I just about
walked away from the model.
I just about decided, hey, I'm just the sales guy.
I don't know if I'm cut out to be an entrepreneur.
Maybe I should just go sell for somebody else.
I was this I was this close.
I even had the deal in place, the commission, the company I was going to sell for.
And I looked at my goals and I wanted to make one hundred thousand dollars a month.
And I started to realize I'm like, Nick, you're never going to get there by doing by going
and selling for somebody else.
You just can't.
It's just it just doesn't work.
Right.
OK.
Yeah.
Maybe there's someone that sells commercial real estate at a brokerage.
OK.
For most people, it's impossible.
And so I luckily I doubled down, tripled down, got really focused and said, I'm going to
sit in this.
I'm going to figure this out.
And I changed my mindset from I'm going to try this for a year.
I'm going to try this for a week.
I'm going to try this.
And whatever I change it until I change it to, I'm going to do this until it works.
And I don't care if it takes five years.
I don't care if it takes 10 years.
This is the model.
And so we went from it's funny.
As soon as I got I switched that as soon as I got focused and I got rid of all the other
side businesses and everything else, I went from eight thousand dollars a month in twenty
nineteen December, July of twenty twenty, we did one hundred thousand dollars per month,
one hundred percent of that was Legion, zero SEO, zero consulting, zero side business money.
That was all from Legion.
And it and it was it was interesting.
I didn't even know.
I just I could just feel the momentum.
I didn't even know we were doing that well.
So that was in twenty twenty twenty twenty one.
We did one point four or five million dollars of top line in just my agency.
That doesn't include, you know, my program.
This was just in my agency.
And I know that because I remember looking at it and going how much of this was and I
think we made a little bit more than that because we just launched.
So in twenty December twenty twenty one, we launched digital landlords.
And the funny thing is, I use the exact same strategy, the same scripts, the same techniques,
the same everything that I teach in the program to sell the program.
And we launched it in December twenty twenty one in the very first year, twenty twenty
two.
We also did another seven figures with the program.
The point is, and I would say the most exciting part, the most exciting part about that is,
yes, we've had a lot of success with the program.
I've had a lot of success with the agency, but the best part is we we've had students
have tremendous success.
So I think you guys have probably seen this name, but Ryan Dalton, somebody that joined
with me like two years ago, just over two years ago, he just hit seventy five thousand
dollars per month, which is absolutely insane.
And so my ultimate goal with what I'm doing in this group, what I'm doing online, what
I'm doing with my program is I want to make I want to create a hunt.
I don't want to take the credit.
I want to help a hundred people become millionaires.
That is my ultimate goal.
And I have the business model that can do it.
And now it's just about finding those hundred people and helping them along the way.
Not everyone's going to become a millionaire.
That's just the reality.
But that is my ultimate goal.
And so that said, guys, that's why I'm doing this.
That's why I'm on here.
And of course, I'm in this for business.
I'm in this for money, whatever the case is, I'm not going to lie about that.
But just so you guys have an idea, those are some reasons maybe you could consider listening
to me.
So my goal with this specific training, guys, is I want to walk you through the pros and
cons of high ticket versus low ticket, including the lessons I learned and the lessons I guess
that I gleaned as I, when I started, jumped into both right away.
And I was trying all kinds of niches and all kinds of cities.
And I didn't know what I was doing.
And I was just making mistakes.
And I'm going to talk to you guys in this on this presentation or this call.
I'm going to teach you guys or talk to you about what worked and didn't work and also
the pitfalls to avoid.
And so the goal for me by the end of this next 30 minutes is I want you, every single
one of you on this call to be able to have enough information to make a very educated
and confident decision on which one is right for you.
And I would also go so far as to say that I don't think there is necessarily a I don't
think it's black and white.
I don't think it's binary.
I think there's shades of gray.
And so maybe for you, based on your situation and your appetite and your goals, low ticket
or high ticket may be for you and other people may be different.
The goal is by the end of this, you have enough information and you are going to be confident
and educated enough to make a decision on which one you want to pursue.
And I would recommend that you do one or the other, which I'll get into in a moment, not
do both.
OK, so I want you guys to be able to know which route you should take to start building
or if you haven't started to start building or keep building if you've already started
rather your rank and rent digital real estate empire.
OK, so what I would like to do to get started.
I don't want this to be like super stiff, me just up there at the pulpit preaching like
a pastor.
But so what I want you guys, if I ask a question and I ask for feedback, I understand some
of you guys may be like on the move or some of you guys may be taking care of kids or
whatever and you can't.
But it would really, really help.
And I pay attention to who interacts.
But if you guys could, if I ask a question, I want you guys to be in the comments.
I want to be able to see what people are saying.
And it just allows me to see who's paying attention and see what the energy is.
So what I'd like to do to get started is number one, as I said, if you guys have any questions
throughout this, I don't care if I'm talking about something completely different and something
just pops in your mind.
Just put it in the chat so I don't forget.
There's no stupid or basic questions.
OK, so what I want to do to start off this conversation, this presentation is I want
to ask everybody to drop a comment with a niche that they are considering going into.
OK, and again, there's no bad answers.
Don't think, oh, I'm going to put this and Nick's going to just tell me I'm stupid because
you guys might not know.
And I will tell you if it's not a good idea.
But I'm curious and I would love to get your feedback on everyone.
Drop a comment with a niche that you are considering going into.
OK, and what I would like to do, well, let's let's give everyone like a minute to do that.
OK.
Also, one thing while you guys are doing that, again, drop a comment of a niche you're
thinking about going into.
Aaron, if you would help me out in addition to admitting people, you just make sure that
everyone's on mute.
I don't hear anyone, but I just want to make sure that we're not getting completely sidetracked.
So somebody new comes in, just keep everyone on mute.
And then when we get to question and answer, we can unmute if you don't mind.
So here's what we got.
We got artificial grass.
Love that niche.
Artificial grass, fencing, good cleaning service, air duct, event photography, heat pumps,
electrical repair slash paving, epoxy garage floors, plumbing, spray foam installation,
garage building, concrete, home interior innovation, house painting.
OK, we've got a good mix.
We've got a good mix.
Gutter installation.
OK, I like these.
And we're going to talk.
By the way, if any of these you guys want feedback on, that could be a question I answer.
And at the end, I could do rapid fire like yay or nay.
And if I have a second, I can tell you why.
Because I've done almost every single one of these that you guys have put out, with
the exception of like, I think I've done all of them.
I don't think I've done home interior renovation, but I do have an opinion on it.
I think I've done the rest of them.
Yeah, I think I have.
And I've failed at a lot of them.
I have not done event photography and I've not done specifically heat pumps.
But everything else I have done.
So I can give you guys really good feedback because I've done it.
So, OK, if there's any more, let me know.
If not, we're going to continue along.
Now that we've got everyone here, what I want to say real quick,
I don't want to say this at the beginning, but the reason that we're doing this new
format, because if you have been in the group for a while, the free group,
I used to just go live in the Facebook group.
And then I had like it was like vanity metrics.
Like, how many people can we get on the call?
Can we get 100 people?
And thank goodness, I've like realized that doesn't matter because I don't care
if there's one person on this call, if there's five, that'd be great if there
was five thousand, but I don't know what it is.
But in every area of my life, I'm just realizing that quantity is so much
better than quality in the content that you produce, in the businesses that you
have or business that you have in the relationships that you have.
All of these things always about quantity.
And so as I told you guys, my goal.
Ultimate, ultimate goal is to help 100 people become millionaires.
That's the goal. And so I look at like, if that's the end goal,
how does everything that I do, the content that I post on my stories,
the things that I do in my Facebook group, do I even have a Facebook group?
What are the the the topics of discussion here?
What are the what what is my my inner community, my digital landlords program?
What does it look like?
How do I hold people's hand all the way to the finish line?
All of that is with the idea in mind, like, how do I get 100 people
to become millionaires? OK. And so for me, as I look at this group,
we just had to like we weren't getting a ton of people that were on the call
that I felt were serious. It was just dead.
And it was it was whatever.
And so we're like, all right, let's do this.
We may only get five people on this call, but it's a risk we're willing to take.
But for me, it feels like the best way that I can help you guys.
Is to work with you more intimately,
where you can ask me questions, where you can, you know,
the things that you normally wouldn't get access to, you will get access.
And this is the most intimate way that I can, you know, assist you
without you being inside of my program.
And so that's why I'm doing this.
That's why I'm going to continue to do this.
And so that's that's why we made that change.
So once again, if you guys stay on this call, for those of you
that joined a little bit late, we are going to be making a free resource
based on the information we present in this call on low ticket versus high ticket.
And it's it's going to be a digital resource.
And Aaron slash Donnie Dre are going to be distributing that to you guys.
You don't have to worry about commenting on a post
if we give a few extra copies away. OK.
Yeah, that said, let's go into low ticket versus high ticket. OK.
So, guys, I'm going to try to get through this part pretty quick
so we can get to Q&A, but there's a few things I want to just
highlight and focus on as we go through this. OK.
So let's just really quickly.
I don't want to assume anything.
I don't want to assume you guys have a certain level of knowledge.
I'm going to pretend everyone's brand new to this business model.
What is low ticket versus high ticket?
OK, I'm going to make this definition really easy.
Low ticket means the price of the service is relatively low.
High ticket means the price of the service is relatively high.
And I'm saying relatively because some things might seem expensive to some people.
Some things might seem cheap to other people.
But we're talking relatively speaking. OK.
What are I'm going to go over a couple of niches that fall into low ticket.
And these just came into my head.
I think, yes, these ones I'm going to mention are all ones that I have personally tried.
So we've got carpet cleaning would fall in low ticket.
Towing would fall into low ticket.
Cool cleaning would fall into low ticket.
Handyman would fall into low ticket.
Locksmith would fall in the low ticket.
There's another one I saw a garage door repair would fall into low ticket.
OK, these are some ideas.
These are some examples of low ticket. OK.
On the other hand, what are some some niches that would fall into high ticket?
We've got artificial grass.
We've got roofing.
We've got remodeling.
We've got foundation repair.
We've got pool construction.
OK, just to give you guys a couple of examples.
And to show you the differences.
Low ticket, high ticket, very simple.
One of them is high ticket for the client.
And typically that usually translates to more money in the business owner's pocket.
Not always, but most of the time, if they're charging more money,
they're going to make more money.
Some of these businesses have terrible margins,
but not usually these services we target. OK.
So I want to talk about the pros and cons of low ticket
and the pros and cons of high ticket.
Again, this is coming from experience.
This isn't like I read a listicle.
This isn't I read an article.
This isn't I talk to my buddies that are in the space.
This is these are my pros and cons from experience.
So let's talk about the pros of low ticket.
And by the way, if there's any pros or cons that you can think of
that I miss, please, by all means, drop them in the comments.
OK, so here actually start with the cons, because then we can end on the pros.
So the cons of low ticket, number one, lower retainers.
OK. And by the way, once again, luckily for you guys,
if you stay on this call, you don't have to take crazy notes
because we're going to create a digital resource
that's going to give you most of this information
that you're going to be able to go and have access to and keep forever.
So stay on this call.
But I'm going to go over these really quick.
So number one, low retainers.
There's not as much meat on the bone.
OK, if you're doing a tow truck deal
and it costs one hundred dollars to go and tow someone's, you know, car.
How much money could there possibly be for the business owner?
Well, they got to pay for their truck.
They got to pay for their gas. They got to pay their driver.
They got to pay their insurance. They got to pay for their uniforms.
By the time it's all said and done, if they actually look at the cost,
they're probably barely making 20 bucks on that deal.
So then if they split that with you, then what?
Every lead you're making 10 bucks.
So you do the math.
If they're on a hundred dollar deal, if you're making ten dollars,
they can share a hundred ten dollars with you.
How many leads do you actually need to get them to charge five hundred dollars,
which is not that much money? Right.
So there is low retainers, typically speaking.
Most often, it's low retainers.
Number two, again, this is my experience.
You can judge. You can call me a hater or whatever.
The business owners in these niches, not always,
but a lot of times are not as a business savvy.
They just don't seem to get it as much as the other niches. OK.
And I believe personally, because it's such a low buried entry
that people could just go start a cleaning company.
I mean, we could add window washing, right?
That's another niche that's low ticket.
And I've also tried literally today.
Lane, Mr. Benson Boone, by the way, I'm not hating.
I love the freaking cut.
I told Kyle, by the way, you do look like Benson Boone, so keep rocking it.
Lane today could go and drop over to Home Depot, buy some whatever.
No one even checks.
Buy some cleaning supplies.
Buy whatever a squeegee and a bucket.
And he could literally today.
Technically, he should go get a license, but technically he could.
If you want to go start knocking on doors today
and he could start a cleaning company, a window washing company. OK.
Awesome. That's really good.
The problem is anyone could do that.
And a lot of people do that.
And so in my experience, you don't get that many business
savvy people, because business savvy people look at the opportunity
and they go, hey, if I'm going to start a business and I can start
a window washing company or I could start a rank and rent digital
real estate company, huh?
Well, this one I could travel the world.
This one has crazy margins.
This one's usually a business savvy person isn't going to choose that.
OK, so in my experience, you're not dealing with as savvy.
I mean, especially towing.
I'm just going to say it.
Like I've dealt with some absolutely tough people in towing
and they just don't understand like what it is to put money into a business.
And get a return.
And it's it's really frustrating. OK.
Number three, con.
You're competing against what feels like a million other marketers
for the same leads.
I know in your head, you're like, well, low ticket should be low competition.
That's what I thought.
And it actually happens to be the opposite.
Carpet cleaning is one of the most competitive freaking niches out there.
If you don't know that, go try it.
It is very, very difficult in most markets to get a carpet
cleaning website to rank on Google.
And when I say competitive, I mean, cost per lead, how hard it is to rank,
how many competitors, et cetera.
Carpet cleaning. And that's not worth that much money.
There's not that much meat on the bone in carpet cleaning.
OK, so you're competing with a ton of other people.
Number four, you need to consistently.
Aaron, check the.
Yeah, you consistently need to produce
much more volume to satisfy the business owners.
OK, you need to just so many more leads
because there's not as much meat on the bones.
What about number five?
Low ticket requires just as much work as high ticket,
but you don't get charged near as much, right?
That kind of goes hand in hand with the lower retainer.
Number six, retention.
In my experience, retention is very difficult.
And you guys have probably heard this, if not experienced it.
But when you have clients that pay you a little bit of money,
they have big problems.
The people that pay you the least amount of money
always have the most amount of questions, the most amount of
they're the most high maintenance.
And I don't know why it is. It's bananas.
Actually, I do know why it is.
It's because that little bit of money means everything to them.
And when you go deal with big clients,
they're used to stroking ten thousand dollar checks.
They're used to spending, you know, having a
check that just came.
They need to write for a hundred thousand dollars in some cases.
And these amounts don't scare them.
But when you deal with these small guys,
five hundred bucks a month is terrifying.
That's that's a heaven forbid.
That's a cell phone bill.
That's another car payment so I can look rich. Right.
OK. And lastly, guys, and I know there's other ones
and you guys can drop them in the comments.
But it seems like a lot of these lower ticket niches
depend more on the GBP.
If you guys don't know what the GBP is,
that is the section at the top of Google.
Again, I'm going to go very basic for those of you that are new.
GBP is the section at the top of Google.
That is the map section.
It used to be called the GMB.
It was also called the three pack.
It's also called the map pack.
It's probably going to be called something else.
GBP Google business profiles.
Tow trucks heavily rely towing heavily relies on maps.
In my experience, carpet cleaning heavily relies on maps.
Locksmith and guys from experience, from literally needing my locks
change at my at my house, I went to the maps and called the first company.
Like that's what I did. Period.
OK, so these these lower ticket niches seem to rely on the GBP.
And as you guys know, the GBP has become harder and harder to get.
Whereas these bigger niches, they don't they don't they don't they're not as much
because people are going to do a little bit more due diligence.
They're not just going to be like, yeah, I need my foundation
or paradigm and I call the first person on Google Maps.
They're going to look at the website.
They're going to do a little bit more due diligence.
They're going to make sure that like it looks credible. Right.
So these are the cons.
Now, there are a few pros.
Number one is a lot of times there's higher volume,
a.k.a. there's more leads available.
So when you're getting a deal and you throw on ads,
as long as the CPC is not too high, you're going to see the movement quicker.
Right. I remember having a tow truck website when I first started to do my strategy.
I was seeing leads come in every day.
Sometimes five, six a day.
And it's exciting.
And you get that little rush and that little dopamine.
You're like, oh, leads are coming in.
And I'm going to pass. I'm going to pass.
So that's good. OK, that is fun.
It's exciting.
So that's a pro. We're not going to deny that. OK.
Another thing that's nice about low ticket,
it's very rarely brand driven, very rarely brand driven.
I would wager to bet
you know, most of you guys, if you needed to get your windows washed today,
maybe, but I would doubt you would know like the top two companies in your city.
And if you do, it's probably because your cousin or your brother has a window
washing company. But apart from that, you don't know any massive companies.
You don't know. And it's because it's not brand driven. Right. OK.
Another another pro is the leads.
Oftentimes, but not always.
I wanted you to remember not always, but oftentimes the leads are cheaper
to acquire with paid ads. OK, again, not always.
But if you go and you look at like the cost per click on towing,
it's usually almost always just a couple of bucks.
It's not if it's above five bucks in towing dog.
That's it. That's that's rough because the money is just not there
to spend that kind of money.
The margins are there to kind of to spend that kind of money. OK.
So typically the leads are cheaper to acquire with paid ads. OK.
And lastly, as a pro is there always seems to be tons of business owners
to talk to. That's a kind of a negative thing because you have a lot of competition,
but it can be a positive thing because you have a lot of people to pitch
a lot of potential customers because it's so low.
The barrier to entry is so low. OK.
So that is low ticket for you guys again to review.
That's like carpet cleaning, towing, pool cleaning, handyman, locksmith,
window washing, pressure washing, gutter cleaning,
not gutter installation, gutter cleaning. OK.
These are just some examples of in fact, I'll add these
so we can add them to the sheet.
So we added pressure washing.
We added a gutter cleaning
and we added window washing just so you guys have some examples
for this digital resource we hand out. OK.
OK. Now let's talk about the.
Pros and cons of high ticket.
OK. And actually, before I do that.
And by the way, I've got about a few more things.
I just got a few more things to share that we're going to go to Q&A.
I want to tell you guys quickly about my first deal.
It's a two minute story.
Just so you guys get an idea.
So my first deal was towing huntsville dot com.
The website is still in existence.
It's awful.
It's hideous and it's hilarious, to be honest with you.
In fact, I don't own it anymore.
I've actually sold it since.
That's how much I don't like towing.
But if you want, it's towing huntsville dot com.
You guys can take a look at it.
It's in Huntsville. It's towing. OK.
I had I knew nothing about towing.
I didn't know any of the pros. I didn't know any cons.
No one told me the pros and cons.
If someone would have told me what I just told you guys about low ticket,
I never would have gone into towing.
I just heard people talking about towing and the group that I was in,
the program that I was in, didn't really give clear direction.
And I was like, dude, towing sounds good.
Let me just build towing. OK, why not?
So I built the site.
By the way, this is back when before I knew that you could pre-sells
before you could cheat the system and get a deal and have them pay for it.
But I was doing the slow method.
I built a site. I did the SEO.
I got lucky because I didn't even know what competition was.
It was just dumb luck. I swear to you, it was just dumb luck.
And I started getting a couple of leads.
And after sending these leads to a couple of different business owners,
I finally got somebody on the hook and I gave them way more leads
than I should have, like two weeks worth of leads.
Probably gave them like 30 leads, maybe even more.
And I did at the time I was doing door to door sales.
I was like in person, like in person is the best.
So I literally went to this tow truck like site.
If you guys have been to towing sites, it's like it's like where they murder people.
It's like a chain link fence.
There's literally dead bodies all over.
I'm kidding. But they look like that.
They have this usually a shitty little office.
And it just screams like money laundering. Right.
Like this is just kind of the vibe.
But I pulled up great Honda Civic in my door knocking uniform.
You know, when inside guns ablaze and do it, I actually put a deal together.
I got a six hundred dollar per month deal, made all the mistakes in the book,
set the expectations wrong, didn't met the business owner, didn't do auto pay.
Imagine the guy cut me a actual physical check that I walked out.
I was like, and I got a physical check for six hundred bucks.
It was like one of three checks that I got over the next six months
because I could never get into pay. OK.
As a side note, just to be fair, that six hundred dollars,
that first deal blew my mind.
It was euphoric, even though it was not the greatest deal.
And the reason why is because it was the first time that I saw
that this actually could work for me.
And I want you guys all to know that that I know you're sitting on this call.
Not all of you, but maybe some of you, maybe most of you, maybe all of you.
And you're sitting there going, yeah, that's cool, Nick.
It's cool that works for you.
It's cool that works for Ryan Dalton.
It's cool that it works for Juan Finesse and Eugene Song
and Patrick Rowland and Jerry Ward and blah.
But but but I'm different in my situation is different.
And I want you to know that we all feel like that.
OK, we all is as cocky and arrogant as I was when I started thinking,
who the heck is that guy? If he can do it, I can do it.
I had that thought.
But at the same time, there was that little bit of doubt, like,
I don't know, man, maybe I'm just not cut out.
Guys, I didn't know.
You have to understand, I did not know that
a domain was the WWW dot.
I didn't know that that's what it was called.
I just thought it was called a website.
I didn't know what SEO stood for.
I didn't know what a backlink was.
I didn't know that there was a way to write content.
I didn't know about Weebly or I sure didn't know what hosting was.
I thought that's what you did when you brought someone over to a party.
I didn't know anything.
Tracking numbers, I knew literally zero.
Like the extent of my technology, I think I had an Instagram account
that I kept deleting during the summer when I was selling
because I was distracting.
I like four posts on Instagram.
That was the extent of my social media presence and my online
technical experience. OK, so I just want you guys to know
when I got that first deal, it was like, oh, my gosh, I can do this.
And even though that deal wasn't the greatest deal,
I still remember walking out with that check, being in that Honda Civic.
It's like a million degrees in Alabama.
I'm sweating when I call my dad and I'm like, Dad, I just got this deal.
And I explained it to him perfectly.
And he's like, I could tell he was like, is this legal?
Like, this is a little sounds a little little sus.
You know, that's kind of the vibe. He's super excited for me.
But the thing about it was I was so pumped
because I at the time was trading my time for dollars.
And many of you guys, if not all of you guys can relate,
unless you punch the clock, you aren't getting paid.
Even if you're a salesperson, unless you are physically present,
you are not getting paid. And I was that person.
I did that for four years, knocking doors in the heat when I was sick,
when I didn't feel like it, when my marriage was having problem,
when my kids weren't well, I had to go out and get my mind right
and put in the hours or else I didn't eat.
And on top of that, I only got paid once.
I didn't get paid every month for these deals.
I got paid one time and then I had to do it again.
So that was I just want you guys to know that first deal
you guys are in for a treat.
And I would love to go back and unexperienced everything
that I've experienced and all the deals and the millions.
I promise you that first deal, it might have been sweeter
than the first million I made.
And I seriously mean that. It was amazing.
So I got my first deal in towing.
Now, the problem is I didn't keep the client.
I kept the client for six months, but I only got paid for like three
because it was like every other month they were not paying.
And I ran into a ton of the common problems
that you're going to run into.
So we started at a flat fee and then he wanted to go to pay per lead.
And me being stupid was like, sure.
And then we started highlighting, well, this is not a lead.
And I had to listen to phone calls.
And I realized his his call answering team was very rude, very unprofessional.
They weren't even trying to close deals.
And then we I mean, I spent so much time to get the six hundred dollars.
OK, long story short, I lost the deal.
OK, and I I think I signed one more guy and then I lost him.
And then finally, I signed a deal with a guy, a great business owner,
signed it, got a contract this time, did it on the flat rate for 500 bucks a month.
And I sold the site. I said, I'm getting out of towing. Done.
OK, that was my first deal.
OK, let's talk about high ticket really quick.
Pros of high ticket.
Let's talk with cons of high ticket. OK, here's the cons. Number one.
The competitors that you do have sometimes can be behemoths.
These can be titans of industry.
These can be 100 million.
And I don't I'm not joking.
These can be 100 million dollar companies that you're competing against
with marketing companies that they bought just to service their companies.
OK, these are the kind of you're going to get some high level people.
Not always, but it can be the case.
OK, so that can be a con.
Number two, if you pick the wrong city in high ticket,
you're screwed because it's almost always more competitive than low ticket
in terms of ranking.
I guess I wouldn't say always because low ticket is weirdly competitive
in some of these niches like carpet cleaning.
But if you don't get the city right, you are screwed.
It is going to it's going to take you all of your energy, all of your time,
all of your margin, all of your resources to rank that website.
And by the time you write the website,
you could have built five more in a better niche in city.
OK, so you have to.
I'm going to call it a con.
You have to there's no room for messing up.
You have to nail the city.
You need to know the right city, what it looks like, what the process is.
And I know some of you guys are in, I think.
So Lane, I saw a few names.
I'm not even looking at the picture, looking at my notes right now.
But a few of you guys just hopped into digital landlords.
I want you guys to focus very, very, very, very, very heavily
on the due diligence process because it matters.
OK, number three, in high ticket, the CPC tends to be higher.
OK, so you have to really do a lot of due diligence at times
to make sure that you aren't getting in over your head
and you're going to be spending too much money.
And guess what? Because the CPC is higher, your SEO matters that much more.
OK, when you're in low ticket and you're in towing, you know,
I've gotten deals before where it's a thousand dollar deal.
This is a real story. Thousand dollar deal.
And I could spend three hundred dollars on ads and I get a ton of leads
and I can make a seven hundred dollar profit split.
Boom. And some of you guys are going, why wouldn't I just do that?
Well, because the truth is, all the other cons, in my opinion,
don't make it worth it. OK, but I have done that.
And I literally did this with a towing site,
which is funny because five seconds ago, I said I got out of towing.
I got out of towing until I met a neighbor in my own city in St.
George that his or her son did towing.
And it just made sense for me to do because I already had the client.
OK, so I pre sold the client, basically.
So I do still have a towing site.
It's in St. George. And that's what happens when I first started.
I had the thousand dollar deal.
I ran the ads until it ranked. OK.
But the CPC will be higher in low and high ticket.
OK, the CPC will be higher 90 percent of the time.
So you really have to do your due diligence, as I said,
and SEO matters that much more.
So you need to nail the SEO because your margins
aren't going to be as good in the beginning, typically speaking.
So you're going to need to make sure that SEO hits. OK.
And lastly, another con that I believe is a con
is because these business owners are more educated,
you need to be sharper.
You need to know a little bit more what you're talking about.
You need to be more prepared. You need to be more polished.
You need to go in with a sales script.
You need to you don't.
It doesn't mean you need to have 15 deals.
And you need you don't need to have sales experience at the gate.
But you need to be scripted. You need to be prepared.
You don't just show up on a phone call with somebody that runs
a 10 million dollar company doing foundation repair
and think you're going to get the deal.
These guys are sharp. OK.
And they get hit up by vendors.
What I'm going to call us vendors, marketers all day long.
And so it's not the same as talking to Tommy, the tow truck guy,
who, like, is just not that smart. OK.
So I think it could be a con because it's a little more intimidating.
But I think overall, it's a pro because, oh, my gosh, I feel so much more.
What's the word edified after talking to somebody
that runs a 10 million dollar company than talking to Tommy,
the tow truck guy who does not just try to survive.
OK. And that's maybe that's bad.
Maybe it's not pros of high ticket. OK.
This is what I want to focus on the pros of high ticket.
Number one, we can charge fat retainers.
When I scaled the 20 in 2020 to 100K, I focused on high ticket.
OK, we could charge fat retainers because there's more meat on the bone.
It's plain and simple. OK.
Number two, this kind of goes in line with the first one,
but you don't need as many clients, meaning you don't need to manage
as many clients and as many problems and whatever.
You can manage a lot less to make a million dollars.
You don't need near as many clients with the high ticket niches
near as many deals to get to a million dollars a year.
OK, it's really not near as many as you think.
And one thing that people don't understand.
And I'll say this as a side note, is if you get a thousand dollar deal.
OK, which let's say that's your first deal.
It's it becomes this thing.
You get your deal and you kind of there's there was this moment with students.
And they're like, oh, my gosh, I just got the first deal.
And all I have to do is get 83 of those, which some
you might think that sounds a lot like a lot.
But when I had no money in my head, I was like, wait, that what I just did.
I'm making a thousand bucks a month.
You're telling me if I just do that 82 more times,
because 83.3 is times 12 is a million.
If I just do that 82 more times, I can become a millionaire.
I can a millionaire defined as making a million dollars.
I can have a million dollar business, dude.
I had a clear path to get there.
And so what I thought was I needed 82 clients, 83 clients.
But what I didn't realize is that I could go into higher ticket niches.
I could charge 2000. I could charge 5000.
And I also didn't realize that if I went after high ticket niches,
there's bigger there's bigger fish out there that you can chase.
That if you do a good job for, they are going to grow with you.
They are going to they are going to want to dominate an area.
And I had a client, I had two clients, one of them ballooned
from like a couple thousand bucks up to like eight, eight K per month.
And I had another client that started at a thousand dollars per month.
I accidentally called this client in an accidental niche because it was a lead
that came on the site in the wrong niche.
And I'm like, let me just call whatever.
And that balloon from a thousand dollars per month flat fee deal.
And one of the months that I was with them, they stroked me a $30,000 check.
So I'm telling you guys this because you sit there and you're like,
I only have a deal. I need 83 of these.
No, you don't.
You need to go and do brick by brick by brick.
But realize if you just take care of your freaking clients
and you'll do a good job and you'll deliver and you'll focus on providing
a service that's really, really good.
You're going to have clients that going to balloon into five, 10, 15, 20,
sometimes $30,000 clients, if you have a $30,000 client,
dude, you're you're over a third of the way there with that one client.
Now, there's other conversations.
I don't love having clients that have that much control over my business.
But at the same time, that's something you need to realize.
OK, another pro, this is what I also said.
They're more educated, they're more savvy.
You need to be sharper, which could be a con.
But also you just it's more exciting.
I love getting on and I'm talking to a business owner and they're doing big things.
They're making 10 million dollars a year.
That's somebody I want to know.
I want to know somebody.
I want to have conversations.
I want to have a Rolodex full of people that are millionaires.
And so for me, that's fun. That's exciting.
They get it when I'm talking about marketing and I'm painting the vision.
Hey, you're in Dallas and we're going to go to Fort Worth.
Then we're going to go to Arlington and work me and you.
We're going to dominate.
We're going to monopolize this area and they could see the vision
and you could see the vision and you could see your paycheck could be
and they could see the upside.
That's fun. That's exciting.
And I like that.
And you don't find that near as much in low ticket. OK.
There's three more quick pros.
Number four, you're not competing against near as many marketers.
You are competing against big dogs when you when you find competition
and if you go into the wrong city.
But it seems like the marketers, they all stay in the low ticket.
They're all terrified of low ticket.
And I don't quite understand why.
But you don't seem to bump into near as many marketers in the high ticket niches.
I don't really understand compared to these lower ticket niches,
at least in my experience, based on the due diligence process that I have
and the criteria that I have for picking a city. OK.
Second to last, you don't need to produce
near as many leads every month to keep them happy.
You can have months where you send them six leads.
And if you've set the expectations correctly, you're OK.
They're not high maintenance, not near as high maintenance,
because that's what happens when you charge retainers that are fat.
And also because they don't need to close that many deals to pay for your bill.
And they don't need to close that many deals to make the numbers make sense. OK.
And then lastly, again, this kind of bleeds into some of the other ones,
but they they they're just lower maintenance clients. OK, not all.
But if we're looking at 10 business owners and high ticket,
10 business owners and low ticket, I'm going to go ahead and put my money on
eight of the 10 of the the the high ticket are going to be low maintenance.
And two of the 10 of the low ticket are going to be are going to be high maintenance.
Unless I said that wrong, eight of the 10 low tickets.
I mean, you know what I'm saying?
The low tickets, more high maintenance. That's just the reality. OK.
So here's what I want to share with you.
One one last quick story about my first high ticket deal.
OK, and then I'm going to wrap it up and do Q&A.
My first high ticket deal was ironically my second deal ever.
So I got my towing deal and I just happened to to meet this guy.
I was selling door to door and I knocked on his door.
He wasn't interested at all in my my alarm.
I was selling alarm systems. He's like, no, no.
And I looked at his truck and I was like, what do you do for work, dude?
We had this weird rap and he did this thing called foundation repair.
And I was like, you know, I'm from St.
George, Utah. We don't have we don't have I'm sorry.
That wasn't foundation repair. It was a different service.
It was called crawl space.
It was called crawl space encapsulation. Right.
So we we where I'm from, it's only foundations.
It's it's just slabs. OK.
And so I never even knew what a crawl space was.
I was like, what crawl space? What?
And he started explaining to me this model and he even took me.
Imagine, guys, I'm in Alabama.
I'm supposed to be selling alarms. I'm tired of it.
He takes me in his crawl space.
I'm like, you know, this is like out of a murder scene.
He takes me. I'm supposed to be selling.
I'm like one of the the the managers.
And imagine I'm sitting in a crawl space like, look, let me tell you,
look how much cooler it is.
And it's I'm laying in a crawl space with this guy.
I don't even know. And this is where I swear to you,
they hide dead bodies in these things in movies.
And I just had this idea.
I'm like, dude, I do marketing on the side.
I'm actually like I'm completely like just blowing smoke.
I'm just acting like I'm way more important than I am.
Like, I think I could get you some leads.
And he's like, let me call my partner.
So I'm pitching him right there on the spot.
He calls his partner's name Ben.
And he's like, hey, I'm with this guy.
He walks out the side. He's like, hey, me and Ben want to take you to lunch tomorrow.
And I'm like, OK. And I'm like, see you tomorrow.
So I go home.
I will do all the research I can on this niche.
By the way, this was highly competitive, but I just went for it.
And I went I met these guys at Texas Roadhouse.
I still remember exactly what I ordered because I walked away.
I couldn't even eat. I was just too nervous.
And I went in like an absolute dummy.
And I pitched them at give me a thousand bucks to build a site.
And then let's do a hundred dollars per lead.
I didn't know paper lead.
Again, I didn't have a group like this.
I didn't have somebody like me telling me don't do paper lead.
But I went in a hundred bucks a lead, a thousand bucks up front.
And they shook my hand and gave me the thousand dollar check.
And I walked out and I felt euphoric.
Again, got a thousand bucks.
I'm the best salesman ever.
But again, this basically just fell into my lap.
It was by chance.
Here's what happened, though, guys.
It took me 14 months to rank that website.
I didn't know I didn't run ads.
I didn't know I could run ads.
I didn't know any of that took me 14 months to rank this website. OK.
And I think about how stupid that is.
I could have ranked three, four websites.
I could have got to ten thousand dollars a month by the time.
But I did it.
And I got it ranked and I plugged along.
I did the SEO and I made the mistake of doing the paper lead model.
And thank goodness these clients were actually good people and they were honest
and they were actually good closers.
And that's so rare.
So I actually did make some money from this deal.
And what ultimately happened is what always happens is it came down to like,
what's a good lead? What's not?
Oh, this is a duplicate lead.
What do we do about those?
You didn't answer the call.
So is it my fault or your fault?
And there became a little bit of that.
And on top of that, it became ultra competitive.
And my website, it was so much work to keep ranked
that it ultimately didn't become worth the squeeze anymore.
And so in both cases, in my low ticket example, my high ticket example,
I don't have either of those deals to this day.
Now, those were eight years ago.
And it is what it is.
But those were kind of like my extremes, like at the towing is at the low end
of towing or the low end of the low ticket.
And then the foundation repair is at the high like end of high ticket.
OK, here's what I learned from doing both.
OK, number one.
And I think I just barely said this exact same thing,
but I want to just recap on it.
But in both in both cases, I don't have a client, as I said.
And so the problem was, guys, is the low ticket.
Well, hold on one second.
Let me make sure that I there's one thing that I wanted to cover first.
They don't want to skip.
OK, no, I covered that. OK.
So what I'm going to do really quick, again, we have about 12 minutes.
If you have questions,
I'm going to cover one last little thing here.
But I do want to if you guys have questions on high ticket, low ticket,
drop them out.
And then in two minutes, I'm going to go to Q&A. OK.
But just one last thing of what I actually learned.
A couple of things I learned.
Number one is not all low ticket niches are created equally.
OK. And what I mean by that as a side note is low ticket that is recurring.
Can work.
Pool cleaning.
I have a pool cleaner at my pool in the US.
I pay 130, 130 bucks per week.
OK, so 130 bucks per week times that by four.
That's five hundred and twenty bucks a month times that by 12.
That's that me.
I'm worth six thousand two hundred and forty dollars to my pool cleaner
every single year.
And he does not.
And he also charges me for chemicals on top of it.
And literally he comes. It's like a 15 minute appointment.
So he spends an hour.
He literally spends an hour a week.
He spends four hours a month with me and he makes sixty two hundred bucks.
It can work if it's recurring. OK.
Other thing is super high margin.
Low ticket can also work.
OK. Duck cleaning is a good example to get your ducks clean.
We're talking, you know, small houses is less.
But let's say five hundred to eight hundred bucks.
OK. One time deal. OK.
It's something that you should do every like six months.
Supposed to do it.
Typically, I haven't even done it at my house.
But these the margins are insane.
It's like 90 percent profit margin.
So the numbers can actually work.
OK. And thirdly is when I say not all low ticket niches are created equally.
Is low ticket does not always mean low competition, as I already stated.
In fact, some of the niches like carpet cleaning, low ticket is the most competitive.
OK. On the flip side, not all high ticket niches are created equally.
There is such thing as too high ticket, too high of ticket items.
OK. And what I mean by that is if you get too high a ticket, for example,
roofing is high ticket, but it's so high ticket, there's so much money in it.
Solar. It's so high ticket.
There's so much money in it that it's branded.
People are spending tons of money on branding.
People are spending tons of money on marketing.
And it costs a lot of money to rank your website, get leads from paid ads,
get leads organically.
And on top of that, these companies are spending so much money on branding.
It's hard to get leads from a generic website.
So the key is, guys, there's a sweet spot with these niches.
And it's this sweet spot between, you know, it's kind of like the city location.
Or sorry, the I'm sorry.
It's niches is kind of like the city side, right?
So with the city side of the location side,
you don't want to just have the highest population,
but you also don't want the lowest population.
You want the lowest population with adequate search volume.
That's the sweet spot with niches.
You don't just want the highest ticket,
but you want the highest ticket that's doable for you to rank.
That's not so competitive.
So there's like these sweet spots with this picking the city.
And there's a sweet spot with picking the niche.
OK. And so you want to make sure it's high ticket,
but not too high ticket.
It's high enough ticket.
You can charge a pat retainer,
but it's not so high a ticket that it's that it's attracting these behemoths.
It's not attracting these huge, huge, huge companies.
This branding, the billboards, the ad, the commercials, the TV commercials, etc.
OK. And one more side note on the, you know,
high high ticket niches aren't all created equally with high ticket niches.
Like roofing, sub niches can work.
OK, I saw someone put plumbing.
I don't like plumbing.
It's it's a little too competitive for me.
However, the sub niche does work.
HVAC changeouts, very competitive,
but there are sub niches that can work off of that.
OK, anyway, so that said, guys,
lastly, I just want you guys to remember that on top of just picking
like the you know, how high ticket it is,
because that's what we're talking about.
You have to keep in mind that for me to go into a niche
has to fit other criteria as well.
Number one, I still believe in going into tried and true niches,
boring niches until you get to a point where you have, you know,
retired, gotten out of your job.
So that's number one.
Number two is I still believe that has to be phone driven.
Number three, I still believe it needs to be an unbranded niche.
Right. It shouldn't be like a picture niche where people need to see
a ton of your work.
And I also believe that it should be recession resistant.
OK. And I just want you guys to know, as we get into Q&A here,
that if I were starting over tomorrow, I would be looking at niches
that fit those criteria and that are in that sweet spot
in terms of high ticket there.
They're high ticket enough is probably the way I would describe it.
You don't just want to go in the most high ticket
because now you're attracting competition.
That said, guys, as I told you one more time,
if you guys are on this call, we're going to do like
eight minutes of Q&A.
If you guys are on to the end here in five minutes,
we're going to screenshot everybody that's on
and we will get you a digital resource with an outline
of all of the notes from this presentation that is super digestible.
And you guys can basically not take notes on it.
So let's see what we've got in terms of questions really, really quick.
And then also, if if we don't have any questions,
I can start breaking down some of these niches and, you know, yeah, your name. OK.
OK, Tara Wally says Tara Wally said the Senate is going to hope
you can still send me the PDF and a link to the recording.
Could you also talk about home
interior renovation in terms of the average ticket?
I'm not sending the recording.
Sorry, but yeah, Aaron can send you the the resource.
And the reason I'm not sending the recording
because I don't want it passed around.
I want to reward you guys are actually on this call.
Bravo poll says thanks in advance.
Can you drop example of high ticket niches?
Like, yeah, I think you said that earlier.
We did that.
Yeah, those are all high ticket
concrete tree service.
Yeah, masonry can be high ticket fencing.
Artificial grass. Yeah.
Who else was that you, Aaron?
Yeah, yeah, like they're just like we listed there.
You got any more? Yeah, I mean, I mean, I know this is this works
in some areas is you're talking about some niches like roof repair
can be less competitive, but still high ticket.
But yeah, that's one that you want to some niche and very specific
with the location and the margins on roof repair are good
because it's just basically labor.
Makes sense. But no, it's a good point.
Todd says, would you do air duct cleaning or duct cleaning as a keyword?
Dude, I do both.
And I'd look at the keyword research, but those my list.
I know when I built my keyword list, my core keywords,
I think I had both of those in.
I would just look at your keyword research, see which one gets more volume.
That's going to be your main keyword.
That's going to be the one you want to use in your H1.
It's going to be the one you want you want to use your page title.
So that's hopefully that answers.
Laura says the sales cycle factor into your low or high ticket, Nick.
Yeah, some, but like I don't ever go into high ticket.
Laura, basically what she's asking is if it's like a super long sales process,
for example, when when someone's getting their foundation fixed,
they're going to have a longer sales process than your tow truck.
Right. If I get if I'm broke down right now, if I go outside
and I got a flat tire, I got to get it fixed right now.
Right. Like I could take an Uber.
I might be able to get it fixed tomorrow.
So I got to get that thing to the shop. Right.
I mean, they're calling a tow truck or a mobile tire guy.
And funny enough, I'm not fixing it myself.
Just so you know, that's why that's not an option.
That's immediate foundation repair.
It's kind of a decision like the foundation needs to be fixed
and it needs to be fixed soon.
But today or next week isn't going to necessarily change anything.
So it is nice to have those lower sales cycles,
but it doesn't change what I choose to go into.
Keep in mind, as part of my process,
I send them leads.
I don't wait for them to close a deal.
I don't even necessarily wait for them to give estimates.
I just send them leads so they can get a feel of those leads. OK.
Lane says, I'm starting in concrete artificial grass.
Can you go into artificial grass a bit more?
I'm having trouble finding says, yeah, OK.
So artificial grass is a great niche.
That's why I like it. Lane is because.
It is, I believe, recession resistant.
We have cities like Vegas that are saying you have to have artificial grass
for turf by this date, you know, or else.
I'm sure California, if they haven't already, is shortly behind
because that's how California is.
They're professional at implementing these kind of like like paper straws,
which, by the way, are the worst things that have ever been invented.
Anyway, that said, artificial grass, just so you know,
is the niche I used in 2021 to so 2020.
My niche was tree service like my my core niche.
Twenty twenty one was artificial grass.
And I loved the niche because I got I was there was deals.
I was charged twenty five hundred bucks a month.
Like the numbers just work right now.
The key, like like you're saying, is finding the cities
because artificial grass isn't everywhere, right?
You know, there's people that need concrete in every city,
but there's not demand for artificial grass in every city.
And so that's the key.
And so what you also have to realize with artificial grass
is you're going to probably have to go through more cities
and be a little bit more strategic.
You're going to need to do more front end work to find that one city.
You might have to look at 50.
And I'm not kidding. This may sound overwhelming,
but you may have to look at 50 cities to find the one.
But when you find the one, it's going to be a home run.
And so it's kind of like, do you want the work on the front end of the back?
And in my experience, I know when you're first starting,
you want to get that first deal.
And so sometimes you go into the back end work so I can get the money
and I can get excited and that's OK.
But where I'm at, because I've closed so many deals
and I've dealt with so many clients, I'd way rather do 50 due diligence
and then go into the right city.
So also, Lane, shoot me a message.
I know you're inside of our program.
So I'll send you some other ideas as well.
And if I could even say, Nick, real quick on that from my experience
that when approaching like number one, just make sure you have the right keywords.
So like you want to have that.
We talked about this, obviously, in the program, but make sure you have
the keywords have the most volume because you want to do variations.
Just look, there's not only one keyword because some might get more volume
than others. And then also, when you do, whether you're so much
a good planner, like if you can also use strategy to help you
create the keywords for each city, but you can do bulk inserts.
That really helps you rather than just doing one city at a time.
Love that. In fact, Aaron, you should make a video on that
for our group and digital.
Also, by the way, Lane, search inside of digital landlords
for artificial grass keywords.
And I've posted like the keyword, like I've already done the work for you.
So you can look it there.
OK, let's say like two more questions.
Where does concrete sit in verse high versus low?
Concrete's in that sweet spot.
That's why I love it so much.
The thing you're going to run into is it is going to be more competitive
in the sense you're going to run into more marketers.
Doesn't mean that there's not deals.
And you guys go watch my YouTube videos like I've created like three.
Just because you see a marketer or a lead generator
doesn't mean you can't go into it.
You just treat it like another website.
But you are just know you're going to see other marketers.
OK, that's just the reality.
But it fits in that sweet spot.
Amy says, agree, Costco implemented paper straws.
That's crazy to us boycott Costco. Kidding.
Todd says, EG, like Minnesota, my home got some Minnesota folks on here
and do not go in Midwest for artificial grass.
No need. Yes, that's completely true.
Artificial grass. Just be intuitive, right?
Like Phoenix. Vegas, St.
George, I have a St.
George artificial grass site.
I got my grass done at cost.
I've made I make a thousand bucks a month.
It's great. It's not even that big of a city. Florida's good.
You know, it's getting more popular.
That's what I like about it, is it's trending more popular.
And I think it's resistant.
It's recession resistant because of the laws, not because people are going to go,
oh, I don't have much money.
Let me just get artificial grass.
But because of these, so I think you need to consider all these things.
But yeah, Lane, just shoot me a message.
We've got some more ideas, too, because there's just tons of niches out there
that I think you could tap into.
So awesome.
Aaron, did you already do a screenshot of everyone that's on this call?
I did. Beautiful.
I don't know how we're going to get it to Discord user
because I don't know who that is.
Does Discord user want to hurry and drop their name in the chat
so we can get that to them or they I guess they could also comment.
Yeah, I guess that's the only person.
Everyone else, I can see that. I gotcha.
Cool. OK.
Also, yeah, beautiful.
So, guys, thank you for being on the call again.
The purpose of this, like this just matches my goal.
My end goal is to turn 100 people into millionaires. Right.
And for me, I would rather help.
How many we have on there? Like 10, 15.
I'd rather help five people like deep.
I'd rather go deep than wide.
And I think you guys should take like just pay attention to what I'm doing there.
And what I'm doing here is that like I would rather you guys go
and get five clients and take super good care of them and grow with them
and dominate with them and expand to three, four, five deals.
You're going to get to your million dollars way faster
than if you're getting a deal.
You're getting the credit card, you're slamming it through
and you're handing it to your VA and you're just chasing the next deal.
Deep is always better than wide.
And so anyway, thank you guys for being on.
We're going to be doing this every Monday.
Watch for the teaser post on Sunday.
And the people that commented, the people that are active
that I could see in the group that are getting deals that are sharing wins,
they're going to get first priority on these calls.
So thank you guys.
We will see you next Monday and watch in your inbox from Donnie Dre
for the digital resource.
Thanks, guys.